can someone really make money as a
documentarian or is this just really
hoppy can someone make money as added as
making documentaries I mean that's a
little bit of a tough question to make a
for the actual straight documentaries
that you're working I mean when you
consider money I would say the vast
majority of us lose money or you know
you better find some other line of work
the way I think people would make money
or do make money is because of your
Neriah T as a documentary filmmaker you
get to madhu commercials you brands with
other stuff obviously the educational
field you can mix you can make some
money um but it's never I would never
like if you're looking for a field to
make money and I definitely you know as
you can find many many other things that
would make money than documentaries and
that's pretty I know of some
documentarians you you know they've up
they've been nominated for many awards
who don't necessarily make money um what
if you sell it to PBS or it's not still
a selling to pbi you know you get a
certain percentage of money it it's not
a lot once you you know their
distributor contacts of you probably
people on your site kind of probably
have an idea of distributor con
contracts now and obviously TV money is
much more direct but you know you're
gonna end up spending a hundred thousand
dollars on on a documentary or whatnots
that's a lot of money to make up where
you know you can't I don't know if I'm
the best person asset per se uh but uh
because of uh I don't make those social
cut you know I don't make a doc that
would probably be on PBS so I've never
got on that route
you